so about a month ago I was scrolling
through twitch and I came across this
channel called healthy gamer I thought
the logo was pretty dope and honestly it
just seemed pretty different from what
I'm used to seeing on Twitch so I
thought I'd tune in for a few minutes
just to see what was up and then two
hours later I came away thinking how the
hell have I never heard about this
before and what is it well it's
psychiatrist who went to Harvard whose
whole channel revolves around
interviewing other streamers about the
daily grind of being a streamer okay so
this is doctor allo Kenosha but I'm
gonna call him dr. kay so in his day job
he's an addiction psychiatrist but in
his free time he's been researching
video game addiction for the past five
years before officially creating the
healthy gamer website and twitch channel
in 2019 the way he explains it healthy
gamer is a website it's a blog a YouTube
channel and a twitch channel dedicated
to talking about mental health from the
perspective of video games so healthy
gamer is about helping people build
healthy lives and it's mental health for
gamers by gamers so it's like facing the
challenges that you face not just in
terms of getting a job or you know
finding your girlfriend or things like
that but like helping you understand
yourself and so that you can live a life
that you find enriching and fulfilling
and you can also play video games for
fun which is what they're designed for
basically it's a mental health resource
that actually tries to understand the
perspective of gamers one thing that he
talks about a lot is video game
addiction and here's how he defines it
when I asked him about it it's
relatively simple so if it causes a
problem it is a problem generally
speaking if you're playing video games
and it's affecting your professional
life your academic life your personal
life your physical health or your mental
health then that's a problem now there
are two reasons why he kind of created
all of this he told me that thread who
is academic and professional career he
saw almost no research when it came to
video game addiction mainly because the
people that he was working with and
reported
- didn't know jack [ __ ] about video
games you know there are some smart
knowledgeable people who are experts in
the field of Psychiatry there and so I
started asking them about video game
addiction and this was about five years
ago now and was surprised that despite
how knowledgeable and brilliant they are
they just didn't understand it and if
you look at people who are leaders in
the field of especially medicine and
psychiatry they're all older like if you
think about Chiefs of departments of
Psychiatry there they're in their 50s
60s or 70s and none of these people have
played video games and so I sort of
realized like no one really knows what's
going on here the other reason well that
actually goes back to his own college
experience see well these days he might
be a successful psychiatrist with a
private practice and now this weird
twitch career at one point he almost
flunked out of college because video
games dominated his life I struggled
with video game addiction or playing too
many video games started in high school
really became a problem in college when
I was failing just about all of my
classes was on academic probation had
less than a 2.0 GPA and basically woke
up every day started to play video games
and played video games all day went to
sleep early early in the morning like 3
a.m. 4 a.m. and just really wasn't going
anywhere in life so on one hand he saw
absolutely nobody talking about these
issues while he also dealt with these
problems in his own life and so he
decided to do something about it
so he's got a website with a blog the
YouTube channel with a lecture series
that's pretty goddamn funny and then the
twitch channel where he talks to
everybody from the little guy to some
big names like Devin Nash reckful and
destiny this whole thing starts with its
discord server there's channels
dedicated to the topics he discusses
regularly on stream and there's even
this like assignments tab where right
now for example you can write 500 words
about what you think is wrong with the
world
I don't think 500 words is enough and
then the twitch stream starts and it's a
long conversation about honestly a lot
of the topics that we hear about when it
comes to streaming and twitch you so the
first thing is let's just think a little
bit about kind of like a
addictive personalities so a lot of
people that I work with say that they
have an addictive personality and if you
think about it you know they'll say like
okay I used to be addicted to like video
games and now I'm addicted to like sex
or I'm that's not gonna happen
things like burnout and social anxiety
and getting over toxic relationships to
even eSports pros dealing with the
pressure that comes with having that
kind of career I prepare with every
stream and I kind of say like okay
here's an opportunity for me to help one
person I have one hour of my life and
they have one hour of their life and I
don't know what this person needs
because I don't really prepare like I
don't usually talk to people ahead of
time or anything like that it's just I
just show up and they show up and then
the main question that I asked is what
does this person need and oftentimes
that is not a canned answer because
people are different it's kind of like
one big therapy session but somehow it's
entertaining and really relatable that
being said he emphasized the fact that
all of this doesn't replace actual
therapy and well the twitch channel has
been steadily growing
it's a December first interview with
reckful that actually caused its
popularity to go through the [ __ ]
roof reckful is a former world of
warcraft pro and obviously a member of
trainwreck TV and he's also been very
open about his mental health issues on
social media and his words spread about
this psychiatrist streaming on Twitch
his fans thought it would be good for
the two of them to connect at almost two
hours long the interview was extensive
and includes like really relatable
moments like this so tell me what your
experience of depression is okay it's
very hard very hard to explain the
easiest way to explain is I've had years
of my life like this where I wake up
every day and I don't see a purpose for
doing anything and this moment
specifically went viral on Reddit what
do you like about what you're doing I
like I like that I'm trying to give
people something I wanted as a kid what
is what is the who's the focus on who
are you thinking about
[Music]
just people have an experience yeah so
I'll tell you reckful listen carefully
now your depression you're trying to
cure the depression that is growing
within kids outs out there today you're
trying to protect them from what
happened to you dr. K's twitch channel
blew up raffle seems to be doing better
and there was like a million articles
written about this dude I'm I'm happy I
can say with confidence I am actually
day-to-day happy even when I'm doing
nothing and alone I'm happy I've never
felt this way in my life okay I've never
felt day-to-day happy when I'm doing
nothing and alone and I was able to chat
with dr. K about the impact of that big
episode I did the same thing that I do
every time on stream and sometimes I
have to like remind myself that this is
what I'm doing
it's just show up and try to help the
person right I've got one hour with this
guy you know whether he's famous or not
famous or a streamer or just a regular
person like it makes no difference to me
like I have one hour with this person
let's see what we can do and how can I
help how can I be of service
that's my time' that's my duty or
responsibility we hear about burnout and
mental health issues associated with
gaming all the time it's something miss
kip recently talked about t foods talked
about it it's something that eSports
pros talk about all the time as well I
wasn't really but I mean like when I
went to the war chat I I made it seem a
lot easier dude don't cry my sweet tank
it was hard at getting out of the war
and for July and August in September if
I put on such an act on stream that I
was happy when I was miserable every
like I would get off stream and I was
either it was so weird I would get off
stream and I wouldn't talk now obviously
streaming alone in your room for like 12
hours a day can be a really lonely job
and demands a lot of time and now we
have the psychiatrist who literally went
to Harvard streaming on Twitch and
talking about these issues that in part
were caused by the job itself it's like
this weird self-fulfilling prophecy
snake eating its tail kind of thing
and yeah the healthy gamer twitch
channel is growing faster than ever and
dr. K has received insane amounts of
requests to chat on stream and so I
asked him about this difficult
contradiction and so when it comes to
like isn't it ironic that twitch is
causing all these problems and you're
using twitch to help people well yeah
and also like yeah right because we want
to use twitch like technology isn't evil
it's just what you do with it
and I don't think that people have
realized the psychological impact that
being a YouTube influencer or a twitch
streamer has and now that people are
getting wise you have people like me who
are trying to help them and my goal is
that you know we'll be able to help
twitch streamers like be healthy and
happy and also like the gamers watching
at home be healthy and happy think about
it like this right dr. K is objectively
helping people but now there's an
audience expecting something and so how
do you balance those two things I
started noticing things within myself
that I imagine other streamers struggle
with so like when we started to get more
viewers I caught myself looking at my
viewer account and I caught myself
wanting to grow that viewer count oh
that's interesting my mind is
gravitating towards wanting me to have a
bigger viewer count because then I feel
like I'm doing a better job so I like
caught myself and I was like oh actually
that's not healthy at all because there
is this performative acts aspect there
is this sort of sense that I don't want
to disappoint people on stream right and
I think that like that's actually one of
the toughest things is that people now
have an expectation that they're gonna
come on stream and within an hour an
hour and a half I'm gonna do something
magical to transform their lives yeah
I do not care if you don't like Bugs
Bunny and Tweety like that whole well I
don't know what to say that you know
like [ __ ] YouTube it it's all over
YouTube you know